i used to struggle reading the quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app i never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for ios
and android and build your habit with
the quran right now
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters at
home hope you guys are inshallah i'm
here with a very very nice gentleman
he's 21 years old yes his name is hassan
my name is ali how are you doing
so you come from a very very similar
background to myself
so your family is alawi yep same race
same race same race um your dad is
i can say the same as the others like
very close-minded when it comes to like
religious topics such as like yeah islam
some kind of hostility towards islam or
all religions
um yeah i'll say hostility because of
what he believes has been done to his
people okay right he believes
his people were killed by muslims
same same topic so okay that's why he
doesn't necessarily like um
islam as a whole okay so where do you so
you asked a question
yeah so
my first question was how do you
objectively verify the quran or any
religious text in general
because i don't yet believe in the quran
i wouldn't say i will in the near future
um but so how would i objectively verify
that to be
uh to believe okay so objective truths
are
are things that are outside
the subjective
um
subjective
reasoning
yeah thank you subjective experiences so
objective truth is outside the
subjective experience of individuals yes
yeah thank you appreciate that so the
thing is here is that we are looking for
objective truth now i was just like
yourself yeah
a young man who was living a lifestyle
that many young people live today
but when the truth comes to you
you have two options you either lie to
yourself and carry on living in a big
light right or
but see the the thing with lying i don't
believe you can
um you can deny truth
i don't believe in that you can't what i
i believe in undeniable truth so once
you believe in truth you cannot deny it
so i said once you believe in truth i
believe you cannot deny it so a lot of
people say like when they see truth yes
they can deny it but look now i'll give
you an example so
can you right now for 10 seconds deny
your mother never existed you'll never
be able to do that so you can never deny
the belief that your mother never
existed yeah that is one exactly that's
one thing so if i genuinely believe this
was the truth
first of all i could not deny it but
that would so when you when people say
yeah yeah when people say like they can
deny truth yeah they haven't even seen
as the truth yet to deny it that's why i
believe very good point yeah actually
yeah
so they were just they just either they
didn't receive enough information okay
or they won't expect like it wasn't okay
good
when allah talks about kafir when allah
talks about a disbeliever
allah is talking about someone the word
actually means something that is covered
okay you know when a farmer covers the
seed
for it to grow yes now
the reason why they will enter hellfire
is because they know
the truth it's like me
saying my mother never existed and
you're like how could you say that your
mother existed and i'm like no she never
are you are you mad yeah but it doesn't
matter what they say do they believe
that
no no no the point is this yeah they
know that's not the truth
okay but they still i don't know
that's the problem right okay so what
they do is they adamantly deny it's like
somebody's saying i deny that i exist
but it's like it's not about tonight but
you know you can touch yourself tonight
ultimately would that matter
it doesn't matter if i tell it to you it
doesn't matter to us but what it matters
to you is the hereafter they would lose
their hair after it's eternal hell fire
now let's come to the quran
yeah okay so do you want to say
something no i wanted to say like
because so god is testing them right yes
and deep inside they know it's not the
truth but today to you they know it's
the truth they know it's the truth but
they deny it but but see i said they
cannot deny it like i said you cannot
die
my mother didn't it never existed and
you're like no i'll leave it and i'm
like no i'm keep saying to you
at that point it's just delusion
not delusion
the punishment is so severe because not
delusion they are willingly
denying it when they know the truth is
otherwise
at the time of the prophet muhammed
peace be upon him
the prophet stood behind behind a
specific mountain
and he said to his people the quraysh
yeah he was denying him
he said if i was to tell you guys
behind this mountain is an army coming
to kill us
would you believe me
they all said of course we believe you
because we know you to be the truthful
right so they're accepting what that he
was known as a truthful person he had
the best of characters
his own enemies would give him give
their valuables for him to look after
because they trusted him
now he said the following he said how is
it
that you trust me when i say to you
there is an army behind me coming to
kill us but when i tell you on the
messenger of god
you say no we deny that
okay so the point here is that
the issue is with the people that's
denying
because the one that's making the claim
is showing an example an analogy where
he's saying that if there was an army
behind this mountain yes we believe he
will prepare but the moment i see on the
messenger of god you say no i don't want
to hear that
so that is the reason why they fall into
this belief
so
why you said that is very important
because it shows your sincerity
because you are very similar to me
because i i had the same thing i said to
myself if i can say
that if i know that this is the truth i
have to follow it you cannot deny it
yeah exactly you cannot deny so it shows
sincerity yes now what i want to say is
the following
the quran within itself it gives you
criterias to see if it's true or not
okay
now the first one is that allah says in
the quran that indeed we have sent this
book and it is upon us to preserve it so
i was talking to the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him because the prophet
when he was receiving revelation he was
trying to utter it fast and try to
memorize it's up to the muslims to
preserve it
no allah is saying it is upon him upon
him to preserve okay right now is that
kind of a prophecy right if you think
about it because what's happening here
is that allah is telling his prophet
that he will preserve this book now
what's very interesting is that at the
time of the problem of minutes of
planning many people memorize the quran
they knew by heart they knew being
posted portions of it they had it
written down on bones and leather
but nobody actually compiled it
okay
this happened after the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him when he passed away
because there was the battle of yama and
in the back of your mouth a lot of
companions who knew the quran by heart
died
so the thing is that god almighty
preserved it now my
argument is this
if this was from other than your lord
allah says you will find many
contradictions and errors in it so allah
is now given an open challenge an
objective challenge saying
put emotions to a side put a subjective
thing to a side
very clear challenge
there is no contradiction then there is
no errors in this book and it's a
basically a bold claim to find one now
that was the first thing that
shook me a bit because it wasn't both
claimed
i said if i find one error one
contradiction and it's fun okay and i
started that journey
and i look for contradictions and i look
for errors i look for mistakes
i couldn't find it
so now to me it's like whoa hold on a
second now
i have to take this seriously now i need
to take it to the next level okay that's
well and good it's it's it's not hasn't
been contributing not errors but it
doesn't necessarily make it from god
it just means that it's okay there's not
construction errors maybe yellow pages
are not convenient yes see that's a good
point like you don't know if it's
foreign exactly okay so the thing is
but the quran claims is from god which
is the difference so that's why i
started my journey to be like okay
now there are things in here
which
no man could know
prophecies
all right okay so now the thing is how
did they know
now we're going to go to
surah roon
yeah
let's go to
chapter room um room okay let me just
find that
so this is a prophecy
in the quran
chapter 30 yeah
the romans have been defeated
in the nearest land
and they after their defeat will be
victorious within three to nine years
the decision of the mata before and
after the event is only with allah
before the defeat of the romans by the
persians and the defeat of the persian
by the romans
and on that day the believers will
rejoice at the victory given with the
help of allah the most merciful the very
merciful yeah okay he's almighty most
merciful
a promise of allah will give victory to
the romans against the persians and
allah fails not in his promise but most
men do not know now let's stop here for
a second yeah
god almighty is given a historical
fact
now the persian empire and the roman
empire they were big empires yeah
the persians there was a war going
between them but there was a moment of
time where the persians
heavily defeated the romans
heavily okay
so much so
that
them coming back
let alone that
their survival their their existence
isn't
it
it's not impossible
impossible for them to even be existing
now when the persians took over certain
lands they even got heracles
and some historians say that they
chained them up and humiliated them i
mean imagine
taking over america
and then catching biden
and handcuffing him and immediately
and then imagine somebody comes and says
americans
have what lost the war
but guess what americans in about three
to nine years they're going to come and
destroy russia
that's a bold claim and why on earth
would you
get all those odds against you when you
know the situation that's why there's a
historian called edward gibbon he
mentions this and many historians
so the point is this why would the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
jeffrey dies if he was a false prophet i
wouldn't be allowed okay why would he
put all of that at risk by seeing
okay the wrong the romans have been
defeated but the romans are going to be
victorious hold on a second bob
what is expected is what the purges of
one and the persian will still
stay victorious he says the opposite
now
the funny thing which is very
interesting is that allah also says that
the believers will rejoice
history shows that
the romans
defeated the persians
they came back
after a certain amount of time within
that time period and they beat the
persians
okay so
i want to know from you
how
why would he make that claim number one
jeopardizing his prophethood and by the
way it's from the quran
okay so you said why would you make that
claim in the first place the japanese
prophet yes so
the thing is
how do we know he was the one that made
that claim
no the quran
okay but but yeah because you believe
the quran is compiled from prophet
muhammad
right
now i don't believe that
so how would you prove to me that he did
say that oh okay yeah that's fine we
have channel transmission so we have
something called the science of hadith
so for example the quran so what you're
seeing is number one before we even go
to that you want to verify that it was
actually prophet muhammad it wasn't
written let's say by someone else after
him yeah exactly okay okay good question
okay so now we have something called the
signs of hadith
number one okay
the quran when it was sent yeah it would
have to be a mass conspiracy
for it to be what you claim it to be
because number one we have qurans
holy oath from the time that they back
carbon date back to the time of the
prophet peace be upon him yeah okay
number one number two
we have a chain of transmission meaning
for example do you believe in testimony
but wait so sorry i cut you off you said
you you believe there's qurans like
carbon date back to prophet muhammad
right
wasn't
and written yeah but you said the verbal
transmission is the most it's the purest
form right
so what if the written transmission is
corrupt
other times
what i recite you look at the text when
i read the quran my teachers will look
at the text or i will look at it when
somebody is reading to verify is what
he's pronouncing the same as what i'm
reading
they both ate each other but the oral
transmission is the actual form of the
quran that is what is exciting yes yeah
so now do you believe in testimony
but for example how do you know china
exists
have you been to china
[Music]
[Applause]
when he utters this he has his
companions around him
these companies hear and testify and say
we heard the messenger of god pronounce
this just like this
and this verse came down for this now
that testimony we have chains of
transmission my quran teacher has a
chain of transmission from his teacher
to his teacher going back to the
mohammed and altered direct chain
direct chain that's why with signs of
hadith we have a criteria number one the
person in the chain has to be reliable
number two the chain has to be connected
number three the the person in the chain
has to have good memory there should be
no defects and um
and
another thing i forgot so what that
means is each person in the chain so
when we come and say in bukhari
five six books of hadith yes okay
um
another one yeah so in these books these
are the sayings of the prophet peace be
upon him
so we have it's multiple people who are
saying we heard the messenger of god
saying this now with the quran it goes
to another level we have something
called muttawater so in
every
uh
level imagine
five
six
60 people
listening to you saying
i heard hassan say the sky is blue and
he pointed with his finger like this
those 60 people convey it to another
100 people
the 100 people convey it to another
thousand people
it will be a mass conspiracy to say
that they all came together and this
because every one person will come and
say well hold on a second no no no
actually we wrote this 100 years later
so the quran the way it comes to us and
the reason why is the only scripture
that has not been corrupted and altered
like the bible when you go to the bible
the questions say in yourself we accept
our scriptures are changed and guess
what allah says in the quran go to those
who write the scriptures with their own
hands and say this from allah so what
the quran is saying the same responses
are corrupted
if the scripture is going to corrupt it
the quran is false
the quran is prophesied in the same
world to the christians
for writing the scriptures in their own
hands and sayings from allah for a
little poetry prize so what allah is
saying is that this quran is preserved
and the method that we have is quite in
detail i can go into we'll take a bit of
time we have this method a scientific a
a science
method science of hadith yeah it's
called science of hadith if you study it
we'll study a bit so which will tell us
for example that each for example verse
that was that came there was witnesses
so you know when i told you about the
battle of yama
a lot of uh people
abu uh and umar took action that we have
to compare the quran so we don't fall
into what the christian
jews fell into the scriptures
right what was the condition here was
the condition
in order for us to compile it exactly
how the prophet muhammad done it we have
a criteria
anybody that comes and says i know an
entire chapter of the quran has to have
two witnesses that saw him taken from
the prophet muhammad now look at the
criteria
every most people knew the quran by
heart
but the criteria they said that's not
enough
we need two just witnesses
that
saw and heard this person learning from
the prophet muhammad no two witnesses we
don't want it so the whole quran was put
together with each companions come and
say oh i know chapter room off my heart
okay good do you have two witnesses yep
these are my two witnesses so there has
to always be witnesses uh down prophet
muhammed street like family truth yeah
there are none other like
there has to be women's
they had to have
not only the person okay a person has to
be truthful not a liar if he was known
to lie they reject statement
we don't want it from you okay because
you want to be a liar so much so some of
them would even rejected based on bad
moral conduct arguments back in those
days eating while standing with bad
moral conduct don't take from this guy
you can't even eat he's his man
chinese
so the quran was compiled on that level
so for anybody to deny that this was not
that time there has been a message a
massive claim
we have our traditions we have the signs
of hadith we have and we know who's in
the chain
yeah we will not for example this was
invited to like the prophet muhammad
uh
okay so that's that's fine you've proved
to me yeah that uh what prophet muhammed
said yes
um what has been preserved has been
preserved very well not just what he
said what he came down with which is the
quran okay quran is separate to the
hadith
so all of those are preserved
so the reason i'm saying this is this
statement is impossible for it to be a
conspiracy that they came and said 100
years later let's write history what was
in history the persians beat the romans
and the wrongs okay let's write that
down
okay
right okay so he said two points he said
not three points he said this is um god
claims this is i mean this claims this
from god yes it says it's from me and it
claims that god has well preserved it
we have well preserved
and um
the last thing was prophet muhammad i i
told you that prophet muhammad
um oh yeah the words of prophet muhammad
has been well preserved yes the quran is
not the words of the prophet
i mean it's not it's not from but it was
uh it's from god through prophet right
and the prophet to the
it's the companions so the words of god
is well preserved essentially yes and
also the sayings of the prophet muhammad
okay
through the orange tradition
okay so
just because it's well preserved yeah it
goes back to that same yeah it's not
from going no you have it how does that
that that that's one yeah but i know
because just because it claimed this
from god yes and it's well preserved yes
does it still make it true no no but
that's what i'm saying i'm giving you an
evidence of
a prophecy
[Music]
do you have anything for me to look at
these prophecies where can i find the
prophecy no no i'm going through them
with you yeah but where would i be able
to find all the problems yeah i'll give
you i'll give you a list i'll give you a
list of like 100 that's fine let's go
through them one by one right okay so
the first one is what
the romans being defeated yes okay okay
since now i show that we have all the
traditions that show that show that the
quran
was revealed by the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him to the companions okay
that
this claim
why how did he know and why did he make
such a risk why did he take such risk
why do you make such a risk how could he
and how did he get it right
um
hi i don't know i don't know why he
would make that risk
okay what does it say about him because
the thing is
if i do an action for example
if a child not my child runs onto the
road and i jump and see their life
it says a lot about me it shows i'm
selfless
okay
right
yeah um okay i don't know don't you the
only way i can think why he would make
that take that risk yeah is because he
was so certain of the outcome how was he
certain of the outcome this is this is
it's good
but how was he structural
only a person that knows they're
speaking the truth is certain
or someone is the only but what is true
what do you do the truth that the romans
are going to win
against persians
okay
what's your definition of truth
because you said
this truth that the romans will defeat
the
uh
yeah but um
to me truth
is um it's something that's that's
outside
the subjective truth is what the facts
are that's how i see truth it's it's a
it's an undeniable fact yeah
okay so so okay so what i'm saying is
when he made this claim
is that a truth
okay so what is truth first of all the
truth is what the facts are right
and the fact right a fact is information
that is objectively it can objectively
be verified okay right yes
so can this information be objectively
verified well that's what
objective verification look i can um in
science for example right
i can do many tests
right i can do many tests and
experiments
and
many people can do the same experiment
test to come to the same conclusion okay
you can't necessarily do that with this
situation
imagine you know what i mean well i
can't do this in the same situation
because because even though like okay so
like let's say you said the example like
roma's defeat were defeated this time
you don't you don't know the um
the actual fundamental of what happened
why do you need to know the fundamentals
it's a fact no because because like
let's say you can say like jesus was
crucified right
and then no i'm just making i'm just
gonna make a false claim right jesus was
crucified and then uh
the jews said oh you are god before he
died right
we can prove jesus was crucified right i
mean you don't believe that but see why
don't you believe that because there's
no because because there's no truth in
it i'm not sure if it's a claim
it's exactly but this is also a claim
yes you have to verify no that's not a
claim this is a reality there's a story
in are non-muslim historians like that
edward gibbon and others who have
claimed to this historical fact if
that's the case then we have to deny all
historical historical facts because all
historical facts are based on testimony
nobody was there to see it
so then
it's a historical fact that the persians
defeated the romans right the romans
came back and became the courageous
effect yeah so now the thing is what
we're seeing is
how did the quran prophesied and why did
it find the need to prophesize and put
its own um
reputation at risk
why would it do it why would it
prophesize and and if they did if they'd
done it it came to be what does that say
this is just one by the way i've got
lined up for you i've got a lot
this is one what does it say about it
can it be from human
could be how
i mean
i've read very like i've read a lot of
philosophical um
papers right now written by humans
and uh
like you would read it and you say how
is this from a human like no no no no
like i mean being amazed is different to
see seeing a fat unfold in front of your
eyes a very fat an odd something that's
going to be but it's not a fact
because it's not objectively verifiable
i can't objectively verify what i mean
by objectively verifiable when they say
very fast give me an example